speaking of which
party you talk about quite a bit uh
and uh uh let's look this is a personal
challenge to you let me bring up the
libertarian party yeah
and the personal challenge is to go five
minutes without mocking them
okay in discussing uh and discussing
this idea so first of all
what i'm being troubled
yeah okay i'm being trolled yeah
i'm being trolled okay yeah you remember
the fun friends there was an episode
where chandler had to not make fun of
people like can you go one day chandler
and phoebe starts telling him about like
this ufo she saw
and it's like that's very interesting
nice for you
this is exactly that okay so a true
master would be able to play within
the game within the constraints so um no
i
i'm pretty sure you'll still mock them
but no no i'll stick to the
rules five minutes so first of all
speaking broadly about libertarianism
can you speak to that how you feel about
it
and then also to the libertarian party
which is the implementation of it
in our current system so i think
libertarianism
is a great idea and i think there's many
libertarian ideas that have become
much more mainstream which i'm very very
happy about i remember there was an
article in either new york or new yorker
magazine in the early 90s
where they talked about the cato
institute which is a libertarian think
tank
and they referred to the fact that cato
was against war
and against like regulation with a wacky
consistency
uh because they didn't know how to
reconcile these two things i don't know
what the two things were but i remember
that expression wacky consistency
and it wasn't eve we were all taught and
this is very much before the internet
that there's two tribes and if you're
pro-life
you have to hate gays and if you're for
socialized medicine
that also means you have to be for uh um
you know free speech it was just this
very and like there's a whole menu and
you got to sign into all of them and
that menu is terrible they hate america
they want to destroy it
oh my god those are horrible evil this
is the menu you want and
the libertarian party to some extent and
just libertarians as a whole said
you know you can do the chinese buffet
and take a little from columbia live
from columbia
and have an ideology that is coherent
and consistent analogy ideology of peace
and
uh non-aggression and things like that
the libertarian party
takes its model from like the early
progressive and populist parties from
the early 20th century
which were not very effective in terms
of getting people elected
but were extremely effective in terms of
getting the two major parties to
appropriate and adopt their ideas and
implement them
and in britain as well the liberal party
got destroyed and became taken over by
labor
as the uh alternative party to the
tories um and
have those ideas basically become
mainstreamed
so i think that and the libertarian my
friend who passed away
eric i miss him dearly uh was their
webmaster and his whole point is
if you don't think about it in terms of
a party in terms of getting people
elected but if you think of it as a
party in terms of getting people
educated about alternatives then there's
enormous use for that that was his
perspective and i don't think that's an
absurd
uh perspective but here's some
libertarian ideas that have become
extremely mainstream war should be a
last resort
uh this is something we're taught as
kids and we all say but for many years
it's been like
they don't think of it as the last
resort it's like something's bad well
it's like the first
instinct now it's like let's really give
it a week just a week like what's going
on in syria is there really gonna be a
genocide the kurds
you know things like that so that's one
another thing is drug legalization
uh this was you know when you and i were
kids oh it's crazy it's only hippies
want to smoke pot
now it's like with it i was on a grand
jury and
the point out people make is are you
sure
that this 16 year old who's selling
wheat let's say selling
should his life be ruined should he be
imprisoned with rapists and murderers
like
if you say yes say yes but you
but are you sure you have to acknowledge
that that's what you're meaning
and then a lot of people are like wait a
minute there's got to be a third option
then
he has no consequences or he's
imprisoned with a rapist like i'm not
comfortable with either of these
uh and i think the other one is a
increasing skepticism
this libertarians were on top of this
first and the hard left of the police
uh as of now asset forfeiture steals
more from people than burglaries what
people don't know about what that's
their forfeiture is if the cops come to
your house and they suspect you you
haven't been convicted
of using your car or your house or
whatever in terms of selling drugs
they can take whatever they want and
then you have to sue
to prove your innocence and get your
property back it's a complete violation
of due process
people don't realize it's going on it's
a great way for the cops to increase
their budgets and it's legal
and libertarians were like the first big
ones saying guys this is not american
and this is crazy
and now increasingly people and
conservatives and left is like wait a
minute this this is
even if you are selling drugs like they
take your house what are you talking
about
so i think those are some mechanisms
that libertarianism
though but not by name has become far
more popular
yeah it's interesting so the idea yeah a
coherent set of ideas
uh that that eventually get integrated
into a two-party system
yeah the war that's an interesting one
you're right i would want
i wonder what the thread there is i
wonder how it connects to 911
and so on but i i think that i i think
the patriot act
patriot act for people who are
politically savvy
we're like oh okay this is not a joke
this is really a crazy infringement our
freedoms
and both parties are falling over each
other to sign into law
and the orwellian name you don't want to
how can you be against patriotism what
kind of person
you know what i mean so that i think for
a lot of people especially both civil
libertarians on the left
and a lot of conservatives who are
constitutionalists are like wait a
minute this isn't
i'm not comfortable with this and i'm
also not comfortable with how
comfortable everyone in washington is
with it
you're right probably libertarian
libertarians and libertarianism
is a place of ideas which is why i have
a connection to it
like i like i i like the
every time i listen to those folks i
like them i feel connected to them i
would even
sometimes depending on the day call
myself a libertarian well we're all the
spectrum so that's why we're on the
spectrum yeah
but like when i look at the people that
actually rise to the top
in terms of like the people who
represent the party this is where like
five minutes ran out
right i could go i'm allowed you can
go why are they so weird why aren't
strong candidates emerging that
represent
as political like representatives or as
like
uh famous speakers yeah
like that represent the ideology i think
uh libertarians tend to
i think jonathan height in his book uh
in his research he's a political
scientist and he does a lot of things
about how people come to their political
inclusions and
what factors uh um force people to reach
conclusions
and he found that libertarians are the
least empathetic and most rationalistic
of all the groups and by that he means
like they think in terms of logic as
opposed to like people's feelings and
and that has positives and has negatives
uh it would and we have the a b testing
with ron paul
ron paul ran for president as a
libertarian nominee he was the nominee
he got pretty much nowhere in 1998 then
he ran as a
return to republican party as a
congressman for many years from texas
he ran for the presidency in 2008 and
2012.
and in 2008 he stood on stage with rudy
giuliani
and told him that they were here in 911
because we're over there
which would have been a shocking
horrifying taboo a few years earlier
many people were like holy crap this is
amazing giuliana was all offended and
ron paul's like i took some guts by the
way
yeah it did i heard that it was so
refreshing
that not what he said but the fact that
he said something that took guts
it made me realize how rare it is yes
for people for politicians but even
people to say something that takes guts
well it's also the idea that like
you can't even if you think america has
a right
to invade any country on earth as much
as it wants and
kill people as a consequence of war and
blow up their buildings and destroy
their country
you can't with a straight face not
expect us to have
consequences even if there are
consequences from evil people
even if we're 100 of the good guys and
their 100 the bad guys
those bad guys some of them are still
going to try to do something
what happens next you know what i mean
so that kind of concept
that there's any american culpability
was
where america where you know we're the
good guys by definition we're not
culpable
to have people start thinking about what
if there's another way
you know what if we're not there and
then they're not here and we're kind of
doing a back door we're talking so
this was scenario so the fact that he
got so much more traction
as a republican the fact that donald
trump who came out of nowhere
became the not only the candidate but
the president tells people
it's like getting a book deal right you
can either go there's three choices
you can either self-publish mainstream
publisher
or independent publisher the
independent publisher is the worst of
all choices because you're not getting a
big advance
they're not going to be able to promote
you a lot and
they don't get the distribution
mainstream i've done mainstream myself
right
with self i don't have the the cred the
respectability of a mainstream for the
cache it can be uh new york times
bestseller
right let's take six a lot of work but i
get a lot more of the profit
uh if it looks good on the shelf on
amazon looks identical so on and so
forth with the mainstream the benefits
and costs are pretty much obvious to
most people
so the same thing it's like you can
either be an independent like ross perot
or you could be just c's won the party
apparatus which the benefits are
enormous there
but in terms of going third party i
don't know the libertarian party
apparatus other than maybe some ballot
access
is really that efficacious and then
you're going to have a lot of baggage
because if you hear independent
jesse ventura ross perot you think of
the person
now you have to define yourself and you
have to defend the party
that's two bridges for most people
you